welcome to this video playing ties from
the Netherlands let's see reti opening
and yeah white can play c4 and sacrifice
the pawn and he took it he took it let's
see yeah well this is this is very nice
what if you just give up the center for
no particular compensation why does sir
what is enjoying a very very nice
position let's see I can play Bishop
purdy too and be for us one possible
idea the thing is some White's position
is very nice but then of course black is
quite this is quite resilient it's very
passive and not to to inspiring but it's
not like breaking down immediately it
some hunk it down on on these three
ranks and tries to ya just stay solid
one problem is that you cannot really
move don't understand it at all and that
you cannot move anything on the
queenside ok I'll be shot d6 is one move
one Goodman's
okay yeah I've I have some substantial
pressure on the queenside and we are
interesting we are night b7 as a more
that you can you can think about class
probably probably too early mm-hmm I
don't yeah I don't like night see for
much it's it's helping him a bit yeah
this was probably not not so great what
I did
it's a generally helpful would like to
have some exchanges and I allowed that
okay the reason amongst others why white
is comfortable he has the bishop on h7
this Bishop is really a passive piece
well g2 is of course a very nice one
okay the thing is is c5a moves here and
it's not you know yeah it's not really
move I can still go to a 5c 5 I can just
take at the end b7 hangs
after some preparation of course I'd
like to play a fall in b5
okay how to proceed maybe one idea is
Queen a four-night see for Queen a five
and it's a it's interesting before I am
off can the given the right moment
there's also those sacrifices on c6 and
b7 yeah I don't know is simply not
reacting to anything
tending not a queen bee 695 this kind of
stuff and being in general just try to
try to annoy him yellow on f2 that this
is not going to happen okay no way I can
do that Roxy for I first but Queen Queen
takes da just even check made
okay yeah that's all very nice but how
do you actually win the game this is a
strong ceylon open question nights you
for 25 again maybe I should really get
it to one to see 5 at the end
maybe
not sure not sure at all right a4 is
always a five
hmm
my idea is to to trap the rook king f2
III the system the the point interesting
ah the g5 is a very good move
yeah this knife Alden was really bad I
mean not fatal but they didn't didn't
really help better all yeah okay I still
I still can't try with h3 head King III
trying to trap the rook it's still
possible and looky looky aight i have
ninety-seven that's a compliment
Wow
maybe really a fighter
what they come on I can't believe what
this guy is playing it with 15 seconds
time unbelievable check check check skin
no no I know ah why did you know
something else ah any other move just
easy son Don 0 haha Stan late and what
the heck did this guy who looks c4 I
can't believe it looxcie fine nobody is
going to play that moose what is this
for move unbelievable unbelievable
really I'm so shocked deadly see proof
to be human after after all this chak
chak de was it was absolutely insanely
quick at the end yeah yeah I confused
moves of course and it it's made into
for example like this oops
check checkmate yeah yeah I need to
break I need a break Bradley thanks for
watching